do you think a woman should be able to
go to jail if she
has a guy raising someone else's kid so
let's say he spent five years raising a
kid that wasn't his was she aware of it
yes she knew oh
she knew and put him in that situation
because he spent five years of his life
raising the kids so shouldn't she spend
five years of her life in jail i think
joe's no but who's gonna look after the
kid then
you gotta find that job mom's gone
oh good
maybe like a
three-month sentence or something
five years that's extreme i just well i
think having a guy raise someone else's
kid for five years is extreme but i
wouldn't say like jail time maybe just
have to repay him yeah like a [ __ ] yeah
but he can't get back his time
energy investment his emotional
investment looking after a kid for five
years and then go in jail for five years
like i feel like going to jail for five
years it's a lot worse okay let's let's
do one year
i don't think like joe is gonna like
what's that gonna solve
okay so what happens when you can't pay
where do they take you no but you can
pay in installments yeah
that's your
working and if
you're somehow taking care of this child
so you're probably working
i just i just think moving forward
they should go to jail for it because i
think that women should know that like
you can't do that like there's a
difference between there's a difference
between being afraid of a fine and being
afraid of literal jail time like do you
don't you think that would make women
think twice before doing it
i think yeah but just not that long
yeah i don't feel like joe's the right
the right punishment i feel like they
need to go on like a
i don't know like a course or something
or of course
dr phil
is there a course that says don't sleep
with other people when you're in a
relationship and pin it on them
like like ultimately taking away the mom
from the kid at the age of five or
whatever and putting her in jail for
five years huh that's hurting the kid as
well so i think like she said like just
paying installments like
a fine or something but that still hurts
the kid because what if like yeah and
maybe not but that's not as bad as going
to jail
right i guess i guess
i get where you're coming from because
if that was the case then nobody would
ever do that because of the
repercussions of being with your
children so it would be an effective
punishment because if as a mom if you
know you're not going to be with your
child if you do something something and
you're not going to do you just never no
woman would ever do that well it just i
think my point more is whenever like i i
bring up a
more extreme punishment for women like
it just seems like as a society and
usually when i have guests like oh no
don't do that
like but it doesn't seem like it's the
same for men
i just think when kids are involved is
something else
and like yeah but sometimes but men go
to jail for not paying child support
that happens
so why why don't women go to jail for
pinning a little like wasting years of a
man's life
that's a good point
but the the
the man he's going to love that child
either way because
so that makes it worse although although
you're not like dna or whatever like you
you're you're you're gonna be with that
woman because she said and that's your
child so you look so you love her and
you love that's your family like you
can't i don't know i feel like you're
gonna have an emotional bond to that
just because someone says none that's
not your yeah but if you if you break up
you're not obligated to i mean you will
be but after yeah you're still going to
be the child it depends it's it's like
it's like having a friend that you've
grew up with it's like
that's like your brother like you feel
like you like that's your boy like but
you're not actually
um
you're not blood related just not dna
but sometimes
your
friends or people that are not actually
related to you are closer than your
actual family itself yeah
yeah
yeah i mean so because you have a bond
with it the women shouldn't have
consequences or extreme consequences
because you bonded with the kid yeah i
still feel like it should have
consequences but like
i feel like most men if they was looking
after a child for five years they're not
gonna be like nah that's not my child
now
they're obviously at first i'm gonna be
like what the hell maybe like not see
them for a couple months but i feel like
they're still gonna love like that
they've loved that child so it's going
to be like what i'm saying is what if if
that's not your child then she cheated
on you so
most men are not going to stay so if
you're not staying are you still raising
the child whilst not being in a
relationship like so it gets complicated
you wasted five years taking care of
this kid what you're gonna spend another
like 13 that doesn't really make sense
yeah that's true and you're gonna put
all that your time energy resources into
what
so you've wasted all this time and it's
the same thing like men don't get oh
that's too extreme when they have to go
to jail for child support you don't see
people marching the streets for that
but a woman can literally pin a guy
for years
and i i don't think there's any
punishment as far as i know
it's wrong yeah it is wrong it just
seems like there's a lack of like
accountability for women with society i
don't i don't think there's a good
enough reason that's why the woman would
lie about that
lying about a kid being okay she may
have cheated yeah like the woman said
that's your son when it's not your son
like
why would like there's loads oh he
probably doesn't want the relationship
to break up yeah what if he's paying the
bill like if if a girl is paying the
bills and not really attracted to god
because that happens like girls will
marry a dude because he can take care of
her not because she's actually attracted
to her so then she cheats with the guy
she's actually attracted to like
physically yeah gets the kid from him
but takes the resources from the other
guy
the man wastes years of his life
finds out it's not his and there's no
punishment oh oh no that should be a
punishment
so he's essentially a sugar daddy folk
that kid basically i felt like yeah
jail time could be could be a case
that's crazy so like would you
would you then change your mind and say
maybe she should go to jail or do you
stand by it has to be a harsh
consequence because that's crazy doing
all that yeah
what do you think you guys change your
mind still jail no jail
lock her up lock her up
jail go around and if she's like
what's it called like not being um
remorseful or like
being forgiven like saying like no like
i don't know he deserved it or whatever
like i feel like yeah she needs to go to
jail
i think it doesn't matter if she's
remorseful if i steal from you it
doesn't matter if i say sorry i should
go to jail if you pin a kid on someone i
don't think it matters if you're
remorseful go you lock her up i think
the hard part for me is the kid because
i wouldn't want to put a kid in a system
that fails kids all the time sending her
from home to home to home so do you
think they should when other people
commit crimes so like um
i had a cousin that was addicted to
drugs so he would always steal things
because he was addicted to drug
um now he
he didn't have a kid but let's say he
did should the court take that into
accountability or into consideration oh
let's not send him to jail
because
i understand what you're saying
um but i feel like
if you're stealing and you're a drug
addict you're ultimately putting this
kid in danger anyways uh-huh
but if you just told someone which is
really bad as well
that they're their father
you're not putting the kid in that much
danger yeah but you're stealing time and
resources
from another person so in essence like
you could take the drug addict off of it
let's just say he was stealing
like it's the same thing you're just
stealing resources time and time it's
almost worse actually to pin a kid
like i don't i just don't it shouldn't
matter if the person has a kid or not
it should matter like did they commit
the crime or did they not commit the
crime
like in my eyes that should be a crime
do you disagree with that
i don't disagree with being a crime i
disagree with the punishment of five
years of jail
um
not necessarily jail maybe like he said
like three months five months
but five
years um
that's long i just think it should be
equal for how long was he pinned how
long did you how many years did you
steal from him
but i get what you say when you say
stealing time because it is stealing
time but you're also like out of this
like you have freedom of movement you're
like yeah it's love this is a kid like
you're showing love in these five years
but i get where you're coming from but i
don't think it's the same as being in
jail for five years yeah but you're now
you have nothing so you go from showing
love and now you have no rights to that
kid
she can she can kick you out you have no
right to see him you you you built
something for five years
for it to come out empty-handed but
that's something else though if she then
after those five years goes and says i
have a restraining order that's not your
kid
that's something else
but if she continues to say like i want
you to be the father from now on like
yeah yeah
and that's completely something else
than saying restraining order well i
just i think it's like did you commit
what should be a crime or did you not i
don't think any of the circumstances
matter just like if you steal from
someone i don't think it should be oh
were they did they have a reason to
steal what was their mentality all this
stuff no it's like did you steal or did
you not steal
yeah
yeah i hear what you're saying but i
feel like with all
crimes there's always like
there's always a good and there's
there's a crime that you can commit but
there's could be a good reason to
actually do it
like obviously killing and stealing is
wrong as well but if i'm dying on the
street i'm going to rob you for your
sandwich like yeah and like there's root
there's
but but in the eyes of the law they
don't know
i was gonna say as well in other
countries it's um
if you catch your wife cheating on you
you can you can actually be sentenced um
for time
um
i don't know what country is but yeah
but in certain countries if if your wife
cheats on you
or you catch her in the act then she can
be sentenced for time in
jail
um i have a bunch of super chats i'm
going to read so
sentience
okay
this is actually a good point so men do
not get the privilege of paying
installments when it comes to child
support they will be jailed up and the
state is incentivized to do so look up
divorce inc movie if a woman knowingly
causes paternity fraud put her in jail
he was robbed
um tough love
[Music]
our future md the biggest tell that your
girl cheated is
if she gets kit if she gets upset about
a genetic test jail screws up kids but
having a felony with no jail times three
times the money is fine dna tests should
be mandatory
not step daddy season because that would
take away everything
yes
we're not out here to take over the
payments these days because honestly
like paternity tests like because would
you guys agree like going forward let's
say let's say going for like today they
decided to put a new law they said dna
tests are mandatory now you have the
opportunity if you've like done that to
a guy
like tell him now there's no you're not
going to be charged with anything but
going forward if you pull one over on it
like you will go to jail do you think
that's fair
absolutely
yeah
like
like you're talking from a perspective
like
like from this day forward if you have
something nothing will happen if you say
something now but going off the day
after that yeah i'd say that's a fair
point i'd say that stuff yeah they know
the law and they're still committing it
then yeah yeah they know what's going on
consequences
yeah
okay um another another fifty dollars
guys
you guys you're gonna get me a new
camera
uh okay paternity frog fraud is
malicious to the court a man is deceived
into investing his time effort money
emotions into a seed that is not his why
didn't the mother have that forethought
about her child when she lied ultimately
the man was robbed
um five dollars from damien roberts
mandatory paternity testing at birth
even though though if that
happened
expect a large increase in abortions to
avoid accountability on the part of the
women involved
twenty dollars
um i love from goose i love how pearly
has to paint the picture for y'all to
decide if jail is a sufficient
punishment um fifty dollars
okay okay in the u.s courts are hard
pressed um to
oh my gosh i'm sorry guys hard-pressed
to dis disestablish paternity because
someone will have to pay for the child
and the court wants its 66 kickback for
each child support payment until his
name is removed from the birth
certificate he is legally the father
oh my god that's crazy i did not know
that
so a guy could have signed the birth
certificate and he will still have to
pay child support
even though he's not the father until
they legally change it and they're crazy
that's crazy that's wrong that's that's
crazy that's right
no i mean i don't know if that's it's a
comment so i i check it but like if
that's true that's insane i did not know
that
okay well i